قال حاكم بالقرد الروسيه ان مؤسستين
كبيرتين في المقاطعه تعرضتان للقصف ضمن
هجمات تصاعدت داخل العمق الروسي وسط
التضارب روايتين موسكو بشان مجموعات
المقاتلين التي قيل انها توغلت داخل
الاراضي الروسيه للشن تلك الهجمات على
مناطق مختلفه تطورات تتزامن مع تصاعد
هجمات اوكرانيه على مواقع روسيه في دنيت
وماريوبول والقرن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اذا كان ذكرها خبر حلقتنا لنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله تصاعد وتيره
الهجمات على الاراضي الروسيه وكيف نفهم
طبيعته واهداف المجموعات المسلحه التي
تخوض تلك المعارك وايضا كيف نفهم النسق
التصاعدي للعمليات التي تجري على الاراضي
الروسيه تزامنا مع الهجمات النوعيه
لاوكرانيا على مواقع تمركز روسيه في دنيتك
وماريوبل والقرم واخيرا ما مالات مشهد
الحرب وفرص التسويه في ضوء دخول المعارك
مرحله التصعيد على الاراضي الروسيه تزامنا
مع مد الغرب لاوكرانيا باسلحه استراتيجيه
كالطائرات المقاتله
[موسيقى]
اذا هي حرب الاعماق وقد استعرت نيرانها
اكثر فاكثر بين روسيا واوكرانيا يرتبط
الجواب بتحديد من تكون تلك الجماعات من
المقاتلين الذين توغلوا داخل الاراضي
الروسيه لتنفيذ هجمات على اهداف داخلها
تصفها
بفيالق لتحرير روسيا بينما تصر موسكو على
انها لا تعدو ان تكون مجموعات لارهابيين
جاؤوا من الحدود الاوكرانيه ويبدو ان
الرهان الاوكراني يتركز على التطورات
الميدانيه وتسديد ضربات نوعيه ضد الاهداف
الروسيه ليس فقط في الداخل الاوكراني انما
كذلك في الداخل الروسي
في اخر التطورات الميدانيه قال حاكم بيل
جورد الروسيه ان مؤسستين كبيرتين تعرضتا
للقصف كما اندلع حريق وتضرر خط كهرباء
جراء هجمات اليوم المصدر نفسه افاد باسقاط
مسيره في قريه بوبوبكا في منطقه
كراس نوريرسكي واضاف ان شخصا لقي حتفه
بينما اصيب اثنان في قصف اوكراني لمدينه
شبيكنسكي اما حاكم بيسكو فالروسيه فاكد
انه جرى هجوم بمسيرتين استهدف محطه لتكرير
النفط في المقاطعه
[موسيقى]
ولمراقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من عمان الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه لواء فايز الدويري
ومن موسكو الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
فاسيلي فاتيكارف
ومنك مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق
اهلا بكم جميعا معنا وابدا معك فايز
الدويري اذا بخمت سقطت ولكن روسيا تتلقى
الصفعه الصفعه
كيف نفهم هذه المفارقه عسكريا
يعني لا اقول ان هناك ارتباط وثيق بين
معركه باخمت وبين التصعيد الشامل انجاز
التعبير لماذا هذا التصعيد اجده يرتبط
ارتباطا وثيقا بالهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
الان الهجوم المضاد من حيث المفاجاه
الاستراتيجيه لا يوجد مفاجاه استراتيجيه
لكن هناك مفاجاه في المستوى العمليات
والمستوى الاتيكي اي في التفصيلات ساعه
الهجوم اتجاه الهجوم حجم القوات طبيعه
الاهداف الى غير ذلك هذه لا تزال غير
معلومه وتقع ضمن دائره التحليل وليس ضمن
دائره المعلومه واليقين عندما ان يكون
الحديث مرتبط بهجوم مضاد بدات تحضير له
منذ اشهر وكانت معركه باكموت احد
التوظيفات لنجاح هذا الهجوم لانها حشرت
العمليات بصوره كبيره في منطقه محدده
استهلكت قوه بشريه من الجانبين استهلكت
معدات وفرت الوقت للجانب الاوكراني ليحضر
الى الهجوم الان هذا الحجم من الهجوم حسب
التوقعات لا بد له من بدايات هذه البدايات
ستكون بضرب مستودعات طرق امداد نقاط تقديس
احداث ارباك احداث تشويش محاوله احداث شلل
لدى القوات المقابله من اجل انجاح الهجوم
المضاد اذا اي محلل يتابع الاحداث ومسيره
الحرب الاوكرانيه حتى من بدايتها حتى هذا
اليوم عليه ان لا يتفاجا اذا ما قامت
اوكرانيا سواء اعترفت ام لم تعترف
بالعمليات سواء مسؤوله ام غير مسؤوله لابد
له ان يتوقع هذه النوع من العمليات لا بل
يتوقع المزيد منها والتصعيد بها
دائرتها لماذا لانها كما قلت تحدث تشويش
ارباك وافشار للمنظومه افشال جزئي
للمنظومه الاداريه والمجوسيه اذا تمكنت من
تجميرها اسمح لي ان انتقل الى الخبير
الروسي نعم باسيلي فاتي
نعم وصفت
ما يجري في الاراضي الروسيه قبل قليل بانه
صفعات تتلقاها موسكو وهذا ما وصفه بعض
المحللين والمراقبين هل هو تفكير رغبوي من
جانب الغرب ان فعلا الضرر كبير
استراتيجيا وايضا لسمعه موسكو قيم لنا ما
تتلقاه موسكو اليوم من ضربات
[موسيقى]
مسائكم طيب ليس هناك اي ضربات بسمعه روسيا
والحديث عن ان اوكرانيا اجهدت قواتنا
العسكريه في باخموت الذي نسميه ارسم هذا
حديث غير سليم دعونا ننظر للارقام انما
فقدته اوكرانيا في هذا في هذا الموقع فقط
في بعض التحليلات من 55 الف الى سبعين الف
جندي اما ما فقدناه نحن من قوات ومن جنود
الذين انضموا للعمليات هناك اقل من 20 الف
علما اننا نحن من كنا نهاجم كان من
المفروض ان تكون الارقام معاكسه ولكن بسبب
الخبره العسكريه وفنون القتال تمكنا من
الحصول على هذه النتيجه الضربات التي تقوم
بها اوكرانيا بالعمق الروسي هي بالفعل
تحصل تحت موافقه الدول الغربيه التي تستمر
في التصعيد على شكل تسليم اسلحه جديده
ومتطوره لنظام اوكرانيا ونحن مستعدين لهذا
ونفهم ان الولايات المتحده وشركائهم
سيستمروا بالقيام بكل شيء
لزياده التصعيد
لتسخين هذا النزاع السيد اوليكس
ان الولايات المتحده ستفعل كل شيء لزياده
التصعيد ولكن ما يجري حاليا كيف نفهمه
اوكرانيا هل هي
استراتيجيه جديده ضرب الاراضي الروسيه
الضغط بهذا الاتجاه منعرج ستتغير بشانه
الامور
ابتداء من هذه المرحله
في الواقع الولايات المتحده بشكل مستمر
تعلن
وتحاول عن جعل اوكرانيا تلتزم بعدم ضرب
روسيا والالتزام بهجمات على المواقع
المحتله الروسيا لذلك هنا يجب ان نفهم هذا
بوضوح اوكرانيا تقوم
بهجمات
مستخدمه اسلحتها اسلحتها الخاصه المصنعه
اوكرانيا اما بالنسبه للهجمات على الاراضي
الروسيه هناك عنصرين اولا ما يحدث في
برجراد هذه اعمال من مواطنيين روسيين اكرر
هذا هم مواطنين روسيين يقوموا بعمليات
معارضه مسلحه انهم ليس ليسوا اوكران هذه
داخليه اما بالنسبه
للضربات بالمسيرات والصواريخ علما ان
اوكرانيا لا تعلن مسؤوليتها عن هذه
الاعمال ولكننا نفهم جيدا انه في الاغلب
هذا هذه اعمال من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه ضد منشات البنيه التحتيه التي
ممكن ان تضعف قدره الجيش الروسي في الدفاع
فايز الدويري الحديث الاوكراني دائما هناك
اصرار على ان ما يجري جماعات بولغارد هذه
هي هم مواطنون روس وليس لهم علاقه بالقوات
الاوكرانيه ولكن اليس حقيقيا ايضا وهو ما
نقرا عنه كثيرا في الاونه الاخيره انه لا
يمكن ان يتحقق لهذه المجموعه ما تحقق على
الارض لو لم يكن هناك تنسيق بينهم وبين
القوات الاوكرانيه الى اي حد هذا صحيح
والى اي حد هذه الجزئيه ضروريه لكي نفهمها
ونوضحها هنا
يعني
امر طبيعي ان
تنقى اوكرانيا بنفسها وكما قال ضيفك من
اوكرانيا بان ما يجري هو صراع داخلي
والحديث في الاعلام الاوكراني واضح جدا
بان هؤلاء على خلاف مع الكريم وتوجهات
الكريملين ولكن السؤال انت طرحت نقطه هي
النقطه الوسطيه والفاصله ما بين الحديث
الروسي وما بين الحديث الاوكراني وهي
الاقرب الى المنطق والعقلانيه لانه ما جرى
قبل عده ايام عندما تم توغل اليات قتال
كان جزء ولاحظنا وشاهدنا ان قسم منها
اليات غربيه وامريكيه تحديدا اذا كيف وصلت
الى اذا افترضنا انها معارضه روسيه كيف
وصلت اليها كيف انطلقت من الداخل
الاوكراني هي لم لم تنطلق من الداخل
الروسي انطلقت من الداخل الاوكراني اذا
دعينا نعود الى ما اطلق عليه
فيلق حريه روسيا وفيلق المتطوعين الروس
كلاهما العديد دون الالف يقدر ما بين 700
الى 750
وتم اجراء مقابلات مع القادم في كلا
الفيلقين نعم هم يقولوا بانهم روس بانهم
رافضين الى المعارك ولكن انطلاقهم جاء من
اوكرانيا ولابد ان يكون بغطاء اوكراني
ولانه انطلاقهم ودخولهم للحدود ووصولهم
الى عمق بعض البلدات واخلاء سبعه بلدات
ومحاوله الوصول الى مستودع للرؤوس النوويه
يدل على انها عمليه كبيره لا يمكن
للجماعات ان تقوم بها بامكانات محدوده
وقدرات محدوده ومن الداخل الروسي قد يكون
الهجوم على الكرملين قد جرى من الداخل
الروسي عندما الطائرات المسيره لكن ما جرى
خلال الاسبوع الماضي لا يجب ان يكون انطلق
من الارض الاوكرانيه ولكن اوكرانيا لن
تعترف لن تتبنى لانها تقول انها فقط تقات
على ارضها لتحرير ارضها
لن تعترف لاسباب يعني واضحه لان الشرط
الذي على اساسه استلمت الاسلحه الغربيه
كان ان لا تضرب الاراضي الروسيه ولا
تستهدف الاراضي الروسيه ولكن في النهايه
يعني المعطيات كلها تؤدي الى هذه هذا
الاستنتاج يعني المنطق بالمنطق ولكن بغض
النظر عن الاعتراف او عدم الاعتراف
اليس هناك خشيه واوكرانيه من استفزاز
روسيا الى الحد الذي يمكن ان تستعمل معه
السلاح النووي التكتيكي
السؤال بالنسبه لاستفزاز روسيا كان
موضوعيا في عام 2014 حتى عام 2022 عندها
اوكرانيا كانت تلتزم بضبط النفس وكانت
تمتنع عن اي عمليات ضد الاراضي الروسيه
حتى لا
تستفز روسيا على اجتياح اوكرانيا اما الان
بعد ما قامت روسيا باجتياح اوكرانيا
اختفى هذا العنصر والعامل عامل ضبط النفس
اما بالنسبه
لان اوكرانيا لا تعترف بصلتها بالاعمال في
بيلجرد اوكرانيا تقول جيدا واعلنا انه ليس
هناك اي جنود اوكرانيين في تلك المناطق
وفي تلك الاعمال ولكن من المفهوم انه من
الواضح ان اوكرانيا دعمت هذه الفرق اذا
هذا
كلاسيكي بالنسبه لخطر استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه هذا التهديد حقيقي وهو موجود
واعتقد ان هناك اعمال كبيره حتى على
المستوى الدولي
والصين عنصر والولايات المتحده والهند
وامريكا باستمرار ترسل رسائل لموسكو ان
هذه خطوط حمراء لا يجب تخطيها لان بعد
اسلحه نوويه او استخدام اسلحه نوويه سوف
يتغير العالم وسوف تتضرر روسيا ولن تكسب
هذه الحرب باستخدام اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه
بل سوف يؤدي لهزيمتها ولكن اريد ان اسال
السيد
قبل قليل قلت ان سمعه روسيا لم تتضرر ولكن
ما يجري حاليا يجعل الجميع يرون روسيا
بموقف الدفاع وليس الهجوم يعني الامور
تغيرت خلال الفتره الاخيره
وهناك سؤال ما هو الخلل والعجز في القوات
الروسيه وفي القوه الروسيه التي تجعلها
يعني مثل قوه نوويه مثل روسيا تعجز عن
اسقاط مسيرات اوكرانيا قبل وصولها للهدف
كيف يمكن فهم هذا
او ايا كان مصدرها هنا يعني المسيرات يتم
هناك
موضوعين انظروا الى خريطه الاعمال
العسكريه سوف ترون انه بعد تحرير
تقدمنا الى بعد هذه الخطوط ونحن نستمر في
الهجمات اما بالنسبه لهجمات المسيرات نحن
نقصف ونسقط الكثير منها ولكن للاسف فعلا
هناك بعض المسيرات التي تصيب الهدف اما
الحديث عن ان هناك ضرر كبير لسمعه روسيا
فهذا شيء لا يجوز الحديث عنه لدينا قدرات
كبيره لدى روسيا اكبر قدرات دفاعيه ولدينا
ما قد نقرص به العدو بشده اما بالنسبه
للاعمال في بلجره وضواحيها لا اعلم من
المتواجد هناك هل هم للوطن يدعمهم النظام
في كييف ولكن المدفعيات التي كانت تغطيهم
كانت تقصف من الداخل الاوكراني والمعدات
كانت امريكيه والقول ان هذه معدات امريكيه
كانت استولت عليها القوات الروسيه وسرقتها
هذه القوات
التخريبيه هذا شيء مضحك ان اعمال تخريبيه
على اراضي روسيه قد تستفز تستفز روسيا
للقيام برد مناسب ولكن روسيا دوله مسؤوله
وسوف نقوم بكل شيء لازم حتى لا نضطر
لاستخدام الاسلحه النوويه لاننا نعلم
الضرر الذي قد يتشكل اذا ما استخدمنا هذه
الاسلحه ونحن نريد ان نعيد الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لنا ولا نريد ان نقصفها نوويا
اذا سمحتي اريد
هذه العقلانيه التي تتحدث عنها اريد ان
اسالك اللواء فايز الدويري هل يمكن ان
تتبدد اذا ما يعني استمرت الاعمال هذه ضد
الاراضي الروسيه
والتزايدت كيف ترى انت هل هناك نقطه معينه
يمكن ان تدفع بوتين لاستعمال السلاح
النووي التكتيكي اذا تقطعت السبل الامامه
وبغض النظر عن موقف الهند والصين واي جهه
تحذره من ذلك
يعني المواقف المواقف الرسميه الروسيه
متباينه جدا حول هذا الشيء اذا ذهبنا الى
تصريحات الرئيس بوتين نجد ان لا يزال
وضع السلاح النووي في مجال الاستخدام
الطبيعي وهو كسلاح ردح لكن اذا ذهبنا الى
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الوطني الرئيس
السابق يقول بان الحديث عن الضربه
الاشتباقيه مشروطا بتزويد اوكرانيا اذا
الموقف العام من خلال العقيد النووي
الروسيه اقول حتى اللحظه التي اتحدث بها
لا يوجد من الاعمال ما يبرر استخدام سواء
سلاح النووي او ما دون السلاح النووي
واقصد به القنابل
القذره وبالتالي حتى هذه اللحظه حجم
النجاحات الاوكرانيه لا يجبر روسيا على
استخدام او التفكير باستخدام السلاح
النووي التكتيكي لكن
ما هي معالات اذا ما اذا ما حصل له هجوم
المضاد ما هي النجاحات التي يحققها هل
الخطه الاوكرانيه التي تم
يمكن قراءتها من بين السطور الوصول الى
ازوف الوصول الى القرن محاوله دخول القرن
في تلك اللحظه قد يحدث تغير في التوجه
الروسي نحو استخدام السلاح النووي
التكتيكي بادنى حجم ممكن للقنابل النوويه
بحيث لا تتجاوز واحد الى اثنين الى عشره
وهي تستخدم في ارض المعركه ضد التشكيلات
المقاتله وهو هذه النقطه فعلا هي ما يتحدث
عنها والسؤال
ما يتحدث عنه مجلس الامن الاوكراني يقول
انه مستعد لاطلاق هجوم مضاد والسؤال مع
حدود هذا الهجوم المضاد هل فعلا يمكن ان
يطال الدومباس والقرم ام هذا ضرب من
الخيال
[موسيقى]
للاسف اوكرانيا الان ليس لديها
قدرات كبيره
حتى تقوم بهجمات عكسيه واسعه تحرر جميع
المناطق وهذا فهم عقلاني جدا
يجب ان تكون هناك هجمات عكسيه قويه مقنعه
وحاسمه
ولكن لا نعلم اين وكيف ستكون هذه الهجمات
التي سوف تحل جميع المسائل ولكننا نتخيل
انها ستكون جنوبا حتى حصار القرم ما يمنع
اي هجمات على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ولكن هذه احد التكهنات ولكن لا
احد يعلم
عدم الاداره
لهيئه الاركان العسكريه
اشكرك جزيلا اذا منكيف منك وشكرا جزيلا
ايضا من موسكو للخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي
باسيلي فاتيجرا فاتيجاروف وشكرا
للواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من عمان
وطبعا شكرا لكم مشاهدينا على متابعه هذه
الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر فيما لا
[موسيقى]